hi guys ted floyd here from eight news
now we're looking at perfect weather
this time of the year perfect weather
for everyone to do some hiking so before
you head on the trails lynn cash here
with red rock search and rescue is going
to give us some great advice before you
hit the trails
specifically medical supplies lynn tell
us what everyone should bring before
they hit the trails this time of year
well um
you should bring enough supplies to be
able to take care of any emergency you
have
what i believe in is that not only
should you carry a few medical supplies
with you but prevention is the biggest
thing
so i've brought a few things with me
that um i want to show you
gotcha
most medical emergencies are going to be
things like
too much cold or hypothermia or they may
be hyperthermia or there may be some
sort of a fall where you have cut
scrapes or you might have a spring or a
fracture right most common things
so to prevent those is really a great
idea before you have to treat them
so what i brought along is a couple of
things
one of those is footwear is really
really important absolutely keep
yourself safe out there and to prevent
injuries to your feet and if you get in
trouble you're going to need this so i
have two things that you've received
commonly this is adequate footwear this
is not we see a lot of people out on the
trails with sandals like this and they
just simply are not adequate for that
yeah another thing is to have a hat of
some sort and the wide brim hamp and the
reason for this is not just to keep the
sun off your head but you can evaporate
a lot of water out through your head and
so when you have protection like this it
really helps in terms of preventing that
dehydration and hyperthermia that can
happen or heat exhaustion one good thing
about that i want to point out too is
we're talking to the complete brim
obviously i'm wearing a baseball cap but
the complete brim also protects your
neck as well correct
so let's see another thing that i carry
or that i recommend everybody carry
whether it is the middle of the summer
or whatever is any kind of a sweatshirt
yes or something else and because this
can be used for a lot of other things
you can use it for a bandaging you could
use it for a bulky uh dressing around a
wound you could use it for splinting
that type of stuff so these are useful
items it's also important to note too
lynn that
even though it's warm during the day
once that sun goes down it gets cold
quick that's correct well you need that
specifically
but i think that the most important
thing to carry
and i need to find it here and i
probably don't have it with me though is
a bottle of water in extra water yes
because oh it's on this side over here
extra bottle of water and i carry one of
these specifically for emergencies this
is not my personal supply this is for
emergencies
and the reason why you would carry this
is for two reasons one is because during
the heat of the summer you're going to
get dehydrated uh a person you run
across or if you get into a problem
yourself you're going to need extra
water so an extra bottle of water is a
good thing the other thing though is
that if you become
um
have heat exhaustion then there are
solutions that you can buy
that interesting
um
little packets of electrolytes so when
we sweat we use we lose a lot of water
and that can make us dehydrated and make
us sick during the summer time if you
add a little bit of electrolyte and this
is a commercial kind of a thing and this
is only one brand there are several of
these available in the market but you
add one
of these to one bottle of water and so
you can replace not only the water but
also the electrolytes that are so
important to keep your body functioning
during the summer time
so let's see what else do i have here um
there's some great stuff here
uh
there are a lot of small first aid kits
that are made uh and they're mostly for
guts and cuts and scrapes and little
bruises and things like that and those
are fine but if you don't have one of
those with you i think in the wilderness
if you're out hiking in a place like
this you need to be able to improvise
that's what the wilderness first aid is
about so
you should always carry something to
stop bleeding
you should always have something to wrap
a bandage with
whatever that might be you should have
something where you can create some sort
of splint and you should have something
to protect yourself from the sun
or from the wind and those kinds of
things if you can do those somehow
that's a really
that really helps a lot so i brought a
few things to show you those things as
well sure so for stopping the bleeding
um
rather than carrying a whole bunch of
medical equipment where you have
um so this is my personal first aid kit
i always carry a little pair of scissors
because then you can you can use these
are really useful if you had to cut
somebody's clothes open to see an injury
these are really helpful if you needed
to make a bandage you can cut clothing
with this and you can make a roller
bandage out of it how much are those uh
they're probably five or six dollars and
you can find that basically anywhere
probably on the internet gotcha so um
it is great to carry things like this
which are these um dressings that
are four by four size and then some
band-aids and whatnot but what if you
don't have anything like that a very
useful item
is
a towel
so i carry small towels and these happen
to be paper but the type you get at the
car wash yes these will not fragment
when you get them wet
uh really you could and they're
extremely light yes but you could carry
just a tea towel or something like that
these are good for two things one of
those is if you have a cut for instance
on your arm i could use this to apply
direct pressure and i could stop
bleeding by doing that and then i could
take a wrap and i could put it around
that pretty easily to hold that in place
yeah but the other thing that's really
helpful with these is that if you are
suffering from heat exhaustion you take
your bottle of water that's for your
emergency and you soak down your
ingenious
and and you start bathing yourself
because when you have water on the skin
it evaporates it drops the
surface temperature of the skin and it
immediately brings your body temperature
down so this is an awesome way to
control hyperthermia during the
summertime is simply by being able to
put these around your neck when our team
members come back from deployments and
they come back there they're tired
they're
they look red they're you know they're
hot we give them these with ice water
and they will use these universally to
you know to cool themselves back down
again so a very very useful item one
thing i want to point out too is who
would have thought the car wash towels
the specific wash towels would be best
because with these they don't fragment
like you said so it can get wet you can
use it it's not going to tear apart on
top of that if you get bleeding
it's not going to fragment with the
blood it's going to soak up the blood
not tear apart you can actually stop the
bleeding so car wash towels get these
put them in your backpack that's
fantastic all right
so
uh other things that uh are are useful
um just a single
like it
in a an ace wrap is it yeah commercial
name for it but anyway this is uh this
is just an ace wrap one of these is
enough you can use this to secure a
dressing you could wrap a sprained knee
or a sprained ankle with this
if you have a
wound that's bleeding profusely you can
really put a lot of tension on an
elastic wrap like this and almost create
a tourniquet-like effect so this is
great for stopping bleeding uh for a lot
of other things we all have those too
because we all do sports we have those
for sports injuries and everything else
so you just take that very small and
very light so there's no problem
carrying those so we've been through
something uh with water something to
stop bleeding uh something to wrap with
now we're here with something uh for uh
splinting and i have a variety of things
that can be used for that most of us
carry um hiking poles yes so these can
be used in a lot of ways they are
extendable if you pad this a little bit
you could potentially split a leg you
could split an arm you can do things
like that yeah um and so this is really
useful for that type of thing yeah but i
always they always come in twos so you
can always lend one over your partner
you don't need both of them so that's
perfect if you don't have that these are
other things this is actually a um
a small exercise map
hikers carry these mattresses that they
sleep on
or even if you don't do that this is
great i carry this because if i needed
to sit down on the desert floor where
it's hot and it's rocky and whatnot or
if i have to attend to somebody else
then i have something to put my knees on
but i could also use this for
if you have a fractured you've fallen
with your arm extended like this and
you've got a break right here i can take
this and i can wrap this around
oh yes and i can take that ace wrap and
it's created a a splint uh an artificial
kind of spring like that yeah so this is
all a car part of what we call
improvisation yeah when you have this we
um uh we also like to have the arm
immobilized like this so a sling would
be really hot gotcha well i don't have a
sling with me right so what i have in my
pocket
is
a safety pin
and what i can do with this is that i
can take your shirt and i can wrap it up
like this
and i can safely pin your shirt to the
front of your shirt and now you have a
sling that's changing and all it's just
a safety pin to do that yeah we all have
safety pins at home too
incredible this is some interesting
stuff because um this is basic stuff we
have at home it is yes yes and the
things that you carry with you this is
an inflatable pillow another way to to
um
split things yeah they're very light
they're very compact you can roll these
up stick them in the corner of your pack
no problem these have multiple uses if
you get tired you can take a nap
and then the uh um
sweatshirt can also be used as a bulky
dressing
so if you have an ankle for instance
that needs to be splinted and i'm not
gonna put it on your ankle let's put it
back on your wrist again i'll take this
from you sure then i can just pack this
around is a bulky dressing yes and i can
again wrap it with the ace wrap and then
you have a little bit of support yeah
fractured wrists are fairly common when
people fall like that so does that
happen a lot out here fractured wrist
fractured ankles well when people fall
down they tend to fall with their arms
extended like this and so the impact
goes into the wrist primarily and it'll
go into the shoulder so it's not too
hard to break the wrist right here or to
dislocate the shoulder or actually
fracture up here especially if you're an
older person
protection from the environment is
another thing that's really important
when people become injured they
automatically
are more susceptible to hypothermia but
in this environment too i've had
situations where i've had people that
i've had to attend to and the sun is so
intense for instance in july that you
have to do something to protect them
from the environment so a way to deal
with that is by uh carrying um
i probably don't have this way right now
either but um i carry a i usually carry
a small piece of cloth that is the rip
stop nylon and it's not very big but
it's enough that i could cover up with a
little bit and protect myself from the
wind or it could be used as a sun shade
things like umbrellas are useless when
you get into in high winds but if you
just have a piece of cloth that you can
put over you then and
rip stop nylon is fairly inexpensive
it's another material that you can cut
into strips and you could make it into a
bandage if you needed to
so those are the things that i recommend
is that water something to stop leading
something to
splint with something to wrap with and
something to protect yourself from the
environment one thing out here compared
to some other places is that there is no
shape
no shade out here at all and how intense
can that sun get out here red rock even
though people think hey it's higher in
elevation it's cooler out here well the
problem is
that not only is it very hot here but
the ground also gets really hot and if
you get to a point where for instance
you pass out or you need to sit down and
you have no protection
you're going to sit down on a very hot
desert floor so in july when you're out
at lake mead and it's been 110 degrees
for five days
and you're out there at noon and in a
cloudless sky like this guess what the
temperature on the desert floor is yes
so that's that's a real hazard right
it's almost what we call the heat island
effect that's right basically the rocks
out here heat up too and so it gets very
hot so let's recap real quick the the
top things that people should bring some
necessities real quick real quick some
band-aids and minor stuff
something to stop bleeding so i would
recommend
towels
or
shop towels or anything along those
lines a bottle of water
something to wrap with so an ace wrap is
is really a good way to do that or you
can cut strips of cloth uh something to
for splinting like a um
pole hiking pole or you know you can
even use your sandal yeah you know i
recommend that you not use these right
these actually could be a good
sportiva's yes or something like this
yeah right so something to split with
and be creative and then something to
protect yourself from the environment
lynn cash thank you so much for redrock
search and rescue i appreciate it there
you have it some great advice that
everybody needs to follow before you go
hiking in the winter and even in the
summer